[Música]
a
escala en parís
braulio modo
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español en la que damos la palabra a
artistas gente del mundo de las ciencias
de las artes de la cultura de los
deportes y de la sociedad civil muy
probablemente ustedes habrán visto la
película jurassic park de stefan
spielberg o algunas de otras películas
donde la estrella principal eran esos
aterradores personajes que habitaron la
tierra hace decenas de millones de años
los invitados en esta ocasión a
descubrir la historia y características
de uno de esos personajes de esos seres
imaginen ustedes a un gigante de komodo
además un tiranosaurio rex una orca
gigante y vamos a encontrar entonces a
el individuo del cual estamos hablando y
se trata del tala soteapan atrox para
hablar de ello saludamos aquí en
nuestros estudios a natalie bar de
directora de investigación del centro
nacional de investigaciones científicas
de francia el cener es y también es
usted la directora de la asociación
paleontológica francesa bienvenida a
natalie gracias por acompañarnos díganos
usted quisiera preguntarle cuándo vivió
él hirano tuitán atrox donde fue que lo
encontraron
de la sota a trapsa es un lagarto que
pertenece a un grupo que se llama
mosasaurios que vivían en el final del
cretácico es decir entre 90 millones de
años y 66 millones de años
específicamente de la ciudad
alrededor de
67 millones de años es decir justo antes
del final del cretácico donde ocurra una
amiga extensión en masa de las más
conocidas de la historia de la tierra y
justo antes de la extensión completa del
grupo es decir que te las utilizan a
trump era uno de los últimos mosasaurios
que se conoce en el mundo y ha sido
encontrado en marruecos y muy
especialmente en la cuenca de los
fosfatos de marruecos que están situada
al norte de maracay entre casablanca y
marrakech ahí hay una extensa zona de
canteras explotadas por razones
económicas por una empresa marroquí que
se llama el oficio selección de fosfato
y que existe desde los años
para decir cifras en marruecos es el
primer exportador mundial de fosfatos 60
por ciento de los fosfatos del mundo se
encuentran ahí efectúan exactamente
es un lugar excepcional porque la
explotación de esto este seguimiento y
formativo ha permitido el descubrimiento
de
centenas y centenas de esquelético pues
eso vamos a hablar precisamente qué
quiere decir está las hospital rex cómo
se traduce esto cómo se formó este
nombre que entiendo que es un complicado
complejo un sitio para cada especies que
damos nombre intentamos relacionar con
sus características o el lugar depende
de cada de cada uno y en este caso
concreto está la súbdita viene de tal
azul que quiere decir el mar en griego
titán gigante es decir el gigante del
mar y drops quiere decir muy feroz cruel
así que hay que imaginarse ese personaje
así las características del tablazo
titán a trucos sí sí sí sí
como su nombre lo diga cerrador nombre
lo indica
era un animal muy grande medía como 10 a
12 metros de largo y su cráneo es un
metro 40 te puedes imaginar de aquí
hasta aquí y es muy robusto muy muy muy
robusto los huesos los dientes
y de esto de todo esto se puede deducir
que era un predador al tope de la cadena
trófica
era el aumento de la población era el
mega predador
a la bestia que daba miedo supongo a
todos los otros animales que vivían con
él y se podía alimentar de todo lo que
había debajo de él es decir
otros reptiles marinos
otros mosasaurios más pequeños otros
peces bien grandes
hemos encontrado
restos de
diversos tipos de animales con
trazas de ataque al ácido que quiere
decir que han sido generados y
dirigido a las entendido y
quiere decir que igual como eran restos
muy grandes unos otros bichos no habían
podido comer estos bichos tan grandes
solamente para dotarlo pues ya hacer una
pregunta usted hace referencia
natalie a los mosasaurios a los que
significa estos aparatos nuestro público
en general que quiere decir aulas lo
entendemos fin pero por ejemplo el
tablazo titán siempre vivió en el mar
también se desplaza mentira como los
mosasaurios eran todos los gastos que
imagina un gran jean luc mejor un
lagarto con personas tienen afinidades
con lagartos un lagarto de cómodo pero
lo emplea a 12 metros lo pones aletas en
vez de patas y le pones en el mar y aquí
tiene el y
y era un gigante
especialmente potente que lo hemos
comparado a una
oscar las hojas actuales porque son
mamíferos marinos también muy robustos
con un cráneo espeso corto robustos
dientes muy grandes y en lo que sería la
el equivalente del museo de dallas o
titán atroz actualmente otra pregunta
que tiene que ver con la curiosidad que
despierta de este tipo de
descubrimientos este reptil de que usted
vivió durante el período cretácico
recuerden los jara que corresponde a
este período cretácico yo entiendo que
también había una enorme biodiversidad
no sólo de grandes animales también de
plantas que alimentaban también de ello
pero el cretácico es el último período
del era un mes es único el legado de un
diario que empieza con
252 millones de años y termina a 66 con
la crisis biológica aparición de las
especies de los mismos aura exactamente
y el cretácico entonces es el último
período hay el triásico el jurásico y el
cretácico
y los mosasaurios
únicamente en el cretácico y además
cretácico superior y durante su poca
duración en tiempo es decir 30 millones
de años que no están se han desarrollado
con mucha diversidad de números especies
pero números también tipos psicológicos
diferentes numerosas expresiones
entonces sí sí y que ocupaban todos los
nichos psicológicos que existían en el
mundo marino y compartían estos con los
tiburones que eran también muy activos y
en los fosfatos de marruecos hay también
una cantidad excepcional de tiburones
justamente se van suceda me pregunta por
qué es tan importante la boca va en su
primera respuesta por qué es tan
importante marruecos para el estudio de
la paleontología los países vecinos por
ejemplo túnez argelia todos los países
que están en el norte de áfrica pueden
encontrar este tipo de vestigios de
fósiles
sí y no
bueno sí pero
en marruecos hay tres
super habla de la ventaja ventajas
ventajas porque ventajas es que es
una super explotación industrial
qué quiere decir esto que nos permite
excavar en condiciones fantásticas que
han ido muy al profundidad de la tierra
porque nos dejan superficies para
excavar gigantes y planes y más la
logística si necesitamos una una
excavadora una excavadora todo el tipo
gente para ayudar podemos contar con
ellos si con la empresa tenemos un
convenio desde hace más de 20 años y
siempre ha sido como digo yo
excavaciones de lujo porque toda la
logística está aquí esto es la primera
ventaja la segunda es que los fosfatos
los sedimentos fosfatos preservan muy
bien los restos de manera excepción en
los gestos los olés de vertebrados y la
tercera la más importante es que en
marruecos la serie sedimentarias de los
fosfatos está completa que va del
cretácico
alrededor de 70 millones de años hasta
el lucena es decir 45 millones de años
porque las capas de sedimentación es
fueron colocando como un pastel vamos a
decirlo así sí exactamente y en los
otros países porque exactamente hay
fosfatos en oriente medio próximo medio
en todo el norte de áfrica en el oeste
de áfrica e incluso hasta la provincia
de pernambuco en brasil hay fosfatos
explotados
económicamente pero solamente marruecos
tienes a la vez el cretácico y el
terciario quiere decir que puedes
estudiar durante 25 millones de años la
evolución de la biosfera de la parió
biosfera la evolución de estos animales
está en medio del límite kt tú puedes
estudiar es como un libro abierto
los otros yacimientos por ejemplo en
oriente próximo yo estaba de en jordania
insignia está solamente el cretácico
en túnez hay más el tercer año así que
la serie no es completa en marruecos
tenemos estas tres ventajas así que sin
exagerar podemos ver que es una especie
de paraíso para los paleontólogos
paraíso entre comillas que no está por
todas estas facilidades con las que se
encuentran ahora bien natalie algo que
siempre ha llamado mi atención es vemos
en las películas hacíamos referencia
necesaria para animales con escamas
aletas con unos dientes gigantescos que
tanto hay que es tan cierto puede ser
esto que tanto hay una imaginación del
individuo en la reconstrucción de estos
animales de estas bestias de estos seres
finalmente bueno lo que encontramos
normalmente son los huesos o esos
dientes garras estos son gestos
concretos con esto tú puedes reconstruir
el animal si tú sabes que te el nuestro
por ejemplo tiene la cabeza tenemos
cabezas completas así que podemos saber
qué cara tenía los dientes el esqueleto
y así se ha podido deducir la el tamaño
porque teníamos un ejemplar que medía 10
metros las aletas todo esto
luego viene la piel es esto a qué te
refieres como en unos casos se han
conservado la piel y tiene escamas en
esta piel así que tú puedes saber y
ahora hay
métodos científicos de nueva generación
que te permite incluso de saber es
bioquímica en él no voy a entrar en los
detalles porque no controlo que te
permite deducir si está bien preservado
el tejido
tejido blando los cordones así que la el
paleo a cómo se llama es decir la
reconstrucción en vivo es como la
ciencia va mejorando desde el siglo 19
hasta ahora va mejorando y seguir
evolucionando estamos llegando ya al
final de esta escala en parís
lamentablemente se nos quedan muchas
preguntas como siempre yo agradezco a
natalie bar de su presencia en nuestros
estudios muchísimas gracias ya tienen
ustedes más elementos para saber lo que
es el talaso titán atrox les damos una
nueva cita aquí la próxima semana en
otra escala en parís
[Música]